david now that we know more about the
ufo uap
revelations of the last month are you
ready to say
that the ufos aren't aliens from another
planet
yeah i mean here's the thing i i don't
know how many times i have to say
this i've been asked this so many times
when we talk about
an unidentified flying odd object
or a uap we aren't
implying that the default would be if we
aren't
aware of what a thing is it's aliens
from another planet
and so after the 60 minutes interview
came out with these
uh claims about um these uap
ufos that pilots had seen and some of
the documents that the government has
released
and the indication was we we don't know
what this is because it doesn't
match anything that is ours and it's
appearing to defy some of the
constraints of the physical world as we
understand it and so on and so forth
my first explanation isn't these
are aliens that came from somewhere else
and nobody else saw them arrive no other
plant no other country saw them arrive
to the planet
but then our military pilots i don't go
to that
the simplest explanations to me include
some aspect of this was distorted by the
way that it was filmed which is one
area of study that is being looked at
and the idea that certain camera lenses
can make things look as though they are
moving in ways and at speeds
in which they actually aren't that's one
aspect
the other aspect would be these are
foreign elements of some kind
from an adversary and so we are not
um uh we're being given limited
information
and these this is you know surveillance
of some kind from uh from an adversary
the third possibility would be this is
us
stuff that is so highly classified
that what the government has decided to
do is to allow the pilots to come out
and say what they did but not go any
further and just claim
this is not stuff the us government is
is at least publicly taking credit for
when it actually is some classified
government program and then the fourth
possibility and this is this is like the
cynical one
in some sense uh is that this is
all a disinformation campaign to make
other countries see this stuff and go oh
man they
is this do they have this at the in the
united states
is the is there are these actually
technologies that the u.s has
we are way behind let's try to reverse
engineer this for example
and the idea is a disinformation
campaign to send other countries
on a wild goose chase to stuff that's
simply cgi
all of those possibilities strike me
as far more likely again just an occam's
razor what requires the fewest
assumptions
those all strike me as far more likely
than these are aliens from some other
part of the universe that have
visited us when i sort of said this is
my position a couple of weeks ago
i got 99 emails from people saying david
thank you this
this just makes sense this seems like
the most plausible
way to understand what we've seen and a
few people saying david
obviously these are aliens from another
planet and everybody's in on the
cover-up and you're part of being in on
the cover-up
again that requires lots of assumptions
and complexity so i tend to lean towards
the simpler explanations now for people
who will write to me and say david
do you think that there are aliens i
think that statistically it's likely
there is intelligent life elsewhere in
the universe other than earth
i just don't think this is it arriving
call me crazy let me know your thoughts
that's my best
guess as to what this is as of right now
one of our sponsors purevpn is giving
you 47
off a one-year plan which comes out to
less than six bucks a month
purevpn makes you anonymous online and
you can trust them
they're the only vpn with an always-on
third-party audit
verifying that your internet activity is
not being logged
purevpn keeps you safe from hackers
prevents you from being spied on by your
isp
social media companies government
surveillance it lets you stream
shows and movies that aren't available
in your country
purevpn is super fast with over 6500
servers and you can use it on all of
your devices with 10
devices logged in at the same time you
can try it for a week
for just 99 cents and you'll get 47
percent off a one year plan
which is less than six bucks a month
when you go to davidpakman.com
vpn the link is under this video and
you'll even get an
extra additional 10 off
when you use the code pacman